making news around the world our
exclusive conversation with 90210 star
shannen doherty yesterday we saw how
strong Shannon remains in her fight
against breast cancer but Shannon let
her emotions show when Jennifer perros
asked about the one woman Shannon relies
on most in this difficult time
her mother thank God thank god she's
there thank God she you know we're so
close and we have such a good
relationship and I know it affects her
and I know that she's so strong my mom
is like you know she's still Magnolia
she's a southern girl you know she'll
force-feed me the Giga red chips but
gone from her life is her father John he
suffered a stroke shortly before she did
Dancing with the Stars he died later
that year you know I think constantly
about my dad and that my dad is you know
watching from up above and it's breaking
his heart that his daughter's going
through this so it's hard
Shannon married Kurt is weary anko in
2011 and feared she would make him a
widower when she first learned she had
cancer
and I looked at him and I was like you
better enjoy every single second that
you have with me because I'm going to be
dead in five years and he just burst out
crying and was like you can't say that
and that phase was short thank God
it's no secret Shannon had a falling-out
with some of her Beverly Hills 90210
co-stars
but she remains close with others
including Jennie Garth and Brian Austin
Green I gave her a call last week and
just let her know what I was thinking
about her and Shannon is
I mean she's one tough cookie I love the
way the cheese she's utilizing this to
really try to shine a light and to help
other people and you know I got nothing
but love for her
I know she's gonna come out of this okay
I've heard from quite a few of my
co-stars and they know who they are and
you know I don't feel like I need to
point them out and you know I thank them
from the bottom of my heart for reaching
out to me and in a bizarre turn more
than 25 years ago the iconic series
foreshadowed Shannon's real-life Brenda
Walsh found a lump yeah actually in her
breast
I remember that episode because it
really meant a lot to me it wonder what
is your what weren't you a lump of my
breast
Shannon was just 19 and from the biopsy
in the hospital to the tears and the
fears her TV character lived out the
same things the 45 year old is facing
now with her losing her breast and then
all her hair did you think at that
moment that it actually become a reality
one day back then I didn't I still I was
a kid man I thought that I was you know
vincible I'm just gonna live forever
you